[Music]
time for what to watch with a little
kind of feel like i'm in a spinning
class
there's a reason why we're playing this
song tony you're going to love it you're
going to love it so let's begin though
first with mia poncetto do we remember
mia poncetto
remember yes gail
yeah now it rings about yes
yeah the young woman who was caught on
video tackling a black teenager in a new
york hotel more than a year ago she'd
falsely accused him of stealing her cell
phone she will avoid jail time for that
incident after reaching a plea deal
twenty-three-year-old pancetta walked
out of court yesterday after pleading
guilty to unlawful imprisonment
imprisonment as a felony hate crime so
here's what happened in 2020 poncetto
was seen in a video taken by keon harold
the 14 year old victim's father the
phone she thought was stolen was found
in an uber car in an exclusive interview
with gail last year poncetto claimed she
had not racially profiled the sun and
that she could not be racist because she
was a woman of color
gail you remember that oh i'll never
forget it yes
so under the terms of her plea pancetta
will be spared prison if she continues
counseling and stays out of trouble for
two years she will have a chance to
replead to a misdemeanor charge of
aggravated assault i'm glad she's gonna
get counseling i really do because at
the time she was very young i wasn't
sure if she was just being very bratty
or if she had other issues that she
needed to address so i think that this
is good that she will continue to get
counseling rehabilitation is good yeah
yeah so too
right i still feel for the 14 year old
teenager yes very traumatic damage it's
incredibly traumatic
and and she was so adamant about it yes
she was and she was so adamantly wrong
right exactly right exactly uh all right
time to turn uh the
turntables all right here we go we got
it all right let's see what you're doing
what i'm trying to do here first on cbs
mornings we are hearing from one of this
weekend's coachella headliners
this
is the dj super group swedish house
mafia with the hit don't you worry child
they split up around 10 years ago but
now they are dropping some new music
they're also tony jumping into the
metaverse i got to jump into the better
verse yes i'm a great dancer in the
middle me too i found out no legs no
arms no that's me you're actually
supposed to be me like yes daddy how do
you have arms
that is me in the metaverse uh isn't
that cool yeah so i got a chance to
speak with swedish house mafia in their
first broadcast interview since
announcing that they are reuniting for
coachella steve agnello one third of the
group showed me how you can hear their
new album dropping friday even if you
didn't snag a coachella ticket
imagine if you're if you can't stream a
show and you can't
see us live you can be anywhere in the
world and you can actually take part and
meet other people and and meet us that's
the beauty of it like us connecting to
our fans that's key regardless where it
is um angelo angelo was basically
telling me steve was basically
explaining to me how i can actually
interact with them and listen to their
music and talk to them while i'm in the
metaverse even if i'm not able to go to
coachella and they're they're the
headliner now because kanye's not that
happy
that's a very cool thing of the future
yes you know whenever we now talk about
it first we go tony i know we do i know
because you're our proselytizer
i'm a big fan were you wearing like
sensors on your feet how are you no they
i they i think they took my picture and
then they replicated it what it would
look like for the average person so they
were like they took my little face and
they took my little body and they put me
in there and i that's the first thing i
thought i'm like wow i'm actually
dancing this is how i dance in real life
i just do the head but in the metaverse
i was like all boogieing so it was kind
of cool
let's start with boogie
don't don't do that
the robot that was my big move back in
the day
all right we got one we got one more
story
uh we have an update this is a really
important story actually yes you're
right we have an update on wnba star
brittany griner she's been detained in
russia since february last night wnba
commissioner kathy engelbert said the
league is working with everybody in our
ecosystem that's a quote to ensure
grinder's safe return from russia she
added this is an unimaginable situation
for grinder to be in we're trying
everything that we can every angle
working through her legal representation
to get her home safely and as quickly as
we can greiner was detained back in
february just before the war in ukraine
started after russian officials
allegedly found vape cartridges
containing hashish oil in her life i
think it's important to hear from the
commissioner on that to let people know
she has not been forgotten people are
working behind the scenes to help
brittany really are
all right vlad thank you very much